hi everyone welcome
to this session in the afternoon i hope
you're enjoying yourself at the
conference it's awesome to see a packed
room oh at least half of a room because
the light is really bright when you're
up
up on stage here but we're gonna talk
about application security uh which is
not really a surprise i think at ndc
security but we're gonna talk about why
things are maybe a bit harder than they
should be for developers and hopefully
we can learn some lessons along the way
of how we as a community as a people of
security champion security engineers or
just developers concerned about security
can do a better job in building secure
applications i know the title is not
that great like absec is too hard
there's like a nuance with the question
mark and the exclamation mark um when i
was building this talk i've been brewing
on this for a while actually when when i
was out for walks at home because what
else do you do when you're stuck at home
and a more
interesting title would have been that
the road to absec hell is paved with
good intentions that's like a much more
dramatic team and um maybe there goes
some like really heavy metal song good
with that title and something like that
and
i like the
the drama of the title maybe but
it doesn't really click and and once i
finish the talk i
i realized that
it doesn't really make sense to call
this abstract hell where we're going
because we're going to talk about
good intentions absolutely we're going
to talk about how people
engineers developers security people try
to do the right thing
and eventually what they tried doesn't
seem to work out that well but that's
not really apps like hell right abstract
hell to me is is companies that don't
even care about security they don't try
that don't
give a crap about building secure
software they're just like yeah whatever
uh security is not important that would
be absec hell so the good intentions
part sure that applies the the hell part
not as much the picture was cool though
this is actually a real place on earth
called the gate to hell um it's
somewhere in turkmenistan if you know
where that is um
and it's something that that's from the
70s you should look up the story it's
pretty insane they were drilling for gas
there and something went wrong and
somebody had the genius idea what to do
with gas is escaping like let's set it
on fire that should solve it right and
this thing has been burning since the
70s and it's it's really it's still
burning today so it's kind of applicable
to some abstract issues
even though things are getting better as
jim covered in the keynote this morning
all right before we dive into two
concrete topics let me tell you a word
about myself i'm philippe dreck i'm from
belgium and i run my own company called
pragmatic web security and every word in
that sentence is important pragmatic web
security as in i help developers come up
with pragmatic solutions based on what
they want to achieve with the resources
they have to build more secure software
and i do that through mainly training
like developer training conference
workshops i just completed a two-day
workshop on api security here um to
in-house training and so on and so on
and that's essentially what i spend my
time on usually on complex topics api
security oh open id connect if steiner
stock from before lunch did not make any
sense to you then maybe i can help you
out understanding what oauth actually
does
all right
enough about me let's talk about json
web tokens json web tokens or jots that
that's a good source for some
well misery and pain usually but
also some some really practical use
cases so what's the jot a jot is a
way to represent claims securely that's
a json web token so the thing on the
left actually this is the debugging tool
jot.io the thing on the left is what we
call a jot it's a three part string
header payload signature and it's base64
encoded well each part individually is
base64 encoded and we use that to
represent a bunch of claims and that
signature part the blue part at the
bottom is what we use to ensure that we
can protect the integrity for example an
oat access token is often a json web
token which means that the authorization
server issues it signs it and whoever
receives that token consumes that token
they can verify that signature to make
sure that those claims haven't been
changed that's the mechanism that we
want to use there and we often use that
for authorization purposes so if you
want to call an api with an out access
token that's going to be a json web
token many people build custom solutions
with json web tokens as well it's just a
way to represent that data the spec says
like hey you can encode it like this you
can use it like not use it you can do
these things with that and that's how we
sign the chart and here's a bunch of
different options all right that's the
context here
as you can imagine something we use for
authorization purposes very sensitive
purposes if something goes wrong there
the consequences are kind of dire and
that's exactly what happened with apache
pulsar somewhere last year if i'm not
mistaken yes 2021.
they had a vulnerability in their
application which allowed an attacker to
craft an arbitrary jot which would then
in turn allow them to take over any
account in the system
and it's as simple as i can create if
i'm the attacker i can create a job that
says like oh yeah i am philippe and i'm
an admin and send it to the system and
systems yeah good enough for me welcome
admin and you can do whatever you want
that's essentially the gist of the
vulnerability
i mean when i read a story like that i'm
always interested of course to use that
as a case in presentations or trainings
and this is from the daily speak um a
really good source for security news and
it's
these articles are typically very
detailed like a lot of details and
context and so on so awesome read that
there's a link to a pull request a link
to a pull request that says like here's
the patch to fix this vulnerability oh
yeah awesome let's take a look at what
went wrong here what's what was the
vulnerability and here's the relevant
screenshot from that pull request the
code in red is the bad one the one
that's removed the vulnerable code and
the code in green on the right is the
good one
and we use this
well we this is what was going on and i
looked at that and i was like hmm
that's kind of weird i don't really see
much difference between the green and
the red part yeah sure they're using
different apis a bit but in the end
they're they're both setting a signing
key and and they're they're brushing the
job and taking the claims out and making
some security decisions with that so
what's what's going on here that's kind
of weird
and i when something that's interesting
to me doesn't make sense i i need to dig
deeper that's my phd background kicking
in i'm like
what's going on and i i wrote a little
code example
um in java and i tried this out so i
built this parser builder set assigning
key for our jobs build it and then
autocompleted that parse function
you get six options
and i'm like
all right i'm very familiar with json
web tokens i'm kind of supposed to be
the expert on that and i i looked at
that and i'm like i have no idea which
one i should use
well i kind of know because the first
one is the bad one according to the pull
request and the
third one
is probably the good one but i'm like
why what's what's the difference
so yeah that's interesting
we actually used this example
in the workshop yesterday and people was
like yeah we have no idea we have no
idea what's going on so it's a java
library this is a library in java to
handle json web tokens it's provided
by an
open source contributor and if it's java
there's typically javadoc so let's look
up the documentation well i couldn't
find any there's no javadoc whatever
about this library that's like oh that's
well it's open source right so the
mantra is you can read the code that's
good enough so let's go to the code and
in the code there's actually
documentation so it does exist it's just
not rendered or hosted online so that's
that's already good so we can read the
documentation in this documentation you
don't have to read everything here but
this explains what this parse function
is all about
and i read that and i was like oh
and we used this in the workshop
yesterday and i asked the whole room 28
people
what's where does it say that this
function is insecure and everybody's
looking at that and like
five minutes later everyone's like we
don't know
so i kind of put them out of their
misery because otherwise it would have
taken a while to find this but it never
says anything about hey watch out this
is really insecure if you use this for
verifying json web token so it doesn't
there's a hint though if you scroll look
at the middle there's this throws
signature exception that's the key part
here and it says like if a signature is
found and it's invalid we can throw a
signature exception like yeah that makes
sense if the token if the signature
doesn't match like yeah you should draw
that and the key word here is if
a signature is found
which implies
that if one is not found that it doesn't
maybe check the signature at all and
just returns the claims
like that is
i mean that was obvious right go on
so as a developer i mean no way you can
you can get that out of that and what
does that mean what's the vulnerability
here well the vulnerability is that an
attacker can craft a very special json
web token where the algorithm the
signing algorithm is set to none
which is a legal jot if you look at the
spec it says like oh yeah if l is numb
that means it's a token without a
signature
so there's no integrity protection but
yeah you can do that
so the attacker can craft a token like
this set out to none include arbitrary
claims in the payload purple part and
send it to apache pulsar an apache
pulser is like oh
i have a signing key i'm going to verify
the signature oh there's no signature
oh in that case we're good here are the
claims done validation web token and
that was your vulnerability the token
with alchem looks like this you have the
header that payload and then nothing
behind the dots
and that's the vulnerability that was
present in that system and that was the
mistake that happened
by the developer of apache pulsar
but yeah it's it's probably a one-off
right i mean one developer makes a
mistake let's not create a big drama out
of that i mean come on
everybody has a bad monday
or wednesday or whatever well actually
this vulnerability is quite common you
may have guessed that this is a really
common problem in applications handling
json web tokens in fact attackers know
about that pen testers know about that
and it's so common that there's a plugin
for burp a very popular pen testing tool
to handle json web tokens and that
plugin has built-in support for the elk
non-attack
as in they know that you can change the
algorithm to num modify some claims and
send it back to the system and it will
well if it's vulnerable it will accept
that token without any issues
that's what this means in practice
this vulnerability exists in other
places as well here's an example from a
year earlier the out zero apis an
identity provider kind of very sensitive
apis they handled alzera tokens on
incoming api requests
and this is maybe even worse because
they knew about this problem
because their api code had a check if
alk equals none reject the token
which is like okay that's maybe a bit of
a solution
could have done a bit more but the check
checked for elf none
in lower case
so when attacker was like oh but what if
i provide none with uppercase letters
that doesn't match that string because
it's a string equals not
a case insensitive check and they were
able to bypass that restriction and
exploit well it was a white hat hacker
so no exploitation just a report and
they allowed that to be fixed in the api
json web talk it's always good for some
fun some people
when they came up with json web tokens
some people warned about like yeah this
spec is not the most secure spec we
think is a bad idea
and they went ahead with it anyway and
those people have a grudge against jason
webb tokens ever since maybe for good
reason but i'll leave that in the middle
actually they hate jason webb token so
much that one of them built a website
how many days since the elk since the
jotalknonvone.com
and they keep a counter of how long ago
a new vulnerability was announced and
this is an old screenshot it's not a
recent one there's another case on there
right now but it's an old screenshot to
show you that this happens again and
again because i'm pretty sure that the
uk nhs covet 19 contact racing app was
not built as legacy code it's a new
application built from scratch in 2021
containing this exact vulnerability
which we've been warning about since
which
kind of forces me to ask what the hell
are we doing here
as a security community how is it
so hard for something like this to get
fixed in practice
seven years later we still have
this exact vulnerability and it's going
to keep going on longer and longer
let me let me give you a first take
right here the first takeaway i promised
you some lessons so let's let's try to
add them in between of the depressing
stories um
in the lesson here is include common
pitfalls in your test scenarios whenever
you learn about something weird or if
you think of something weird yourself
write that in one of your tests if you
have an application accepting jots
i expect to see a whole battery of tests
that give it invalid shots like algnon
invalid algorithms invalid signatures
parsing errors whatever and you have to
ensure that all of these get handled
gracefully
not with the 200 okay but with some form
of
maybe i should not accept that json web
token that's a very important case here
an elk noun should definitely be in your
test suite so that you can be the one
catching that issue not an attacker
trying to attack your application that's
take away number one
all right
the title of apsec is too hard
case in point but this is not the only
problem it is in web tokens i wish it
was that would be fairly straightforward
to fix but it takes a lot more to handle
json web tokens securely
so what does it take to do that
correctly
well first of all you have to choose
between a signature scheme because jots
support something symmetric with a
shared secret called an hmac or they
support a digital signature
which one do you use well i'm kind of
giving you a hint here the green is the
suggestion hmacs are very useless when
it comes to jots especially in a
distributed scenario so you want to use
digital signatures signed with the
private key verified with the public key
awesome
that wasn't too hard right so we can
figure that out why not that one out
which signing algorithm do you use if
you want to use digital signatures
there's like a whole bunch of algorithms
supported by the spec with very
meaningful names like rs256
and ps256 it's like oh yeah
i don't know well
i do know ps256 is a good recommendation
why well there's a whole bunch of
details behind it and it's a pragmatic
trade-off between library support and
security and so on and so on and that
one is a good trade-off as in it's
widely supported it's very
straightforward to use very easy to
implement and it's better than rs256
which is considered to be the standard
or most commonly used
next steps well if you handle a jot you
have to verify the signature correctly
kind of important
you have to verify that the shot is
valid and you do that by checking the
signature not accepting an elk non token
that's something we talked about before
and you have to check other things like
a time stamp shots have time stamps
key claims are an nbf claim not before
as in the job only becomes valid at this
point in time and an exp it expires at
that point in time you have to verify
that because you don't do not want to
accept expired tokens or tokens that
aren't valid yet
there's another bunch of reserved claims
all three letter claims for
fun and pleasure there's the iss claim
which is the issuer and the aud claim
which is the audience you want to verify
both like is this not coming from
someone i trust like do i want to accept
tokens from this entity and is it
intended for me if i'm an api and the
audience is like oh no send it to that
guy
then i shouldn't be accepting that json
web token so all of these things is what
you have to do as a developer
it's not because the slide is full that
it's the list is done there's actually
more here
next step we have to ensure that we
support some form of key rotation
because we use a key to verify the
signature on the job but that key can
change at any point in time for security
reasons typically
so we have to support that so that means
you have to use a bunch of claims or an
out-of-band key discovery mechanism to
get the right keys and to maybe able to
update them when necessary all effort on
your end
then there's a couple a couple of best
practices that are more recent like you
should have an explicit type in that
json web token as well like a token has
a purpose let's include that purpose in
the type claim in header so it's very
clear that what that's what the token is
supposed to do
that helps avoid token confusion attacks
in practice so all of this
and a bunch more that i haven't talked
about here
is what we ask from a developer
my question to you is is that realistic
is it realistic to ask all of this from
a developer which has like 10 000 other
things to do and has the same list of
requirements for other topics and for
performance and accessibility and this
and that and that i don't think it is
this is it requires
a lot of expertise in json web tokens to
be able to do this securely
and if you have to do that
over and over again and every
application where you handle shots
that's not gonna work very well and
maybe you figured it out but your
colleague hasn't and if you write it
once and your colleague writes it once
there's gonna be one vulnerable version
or maybe two who knows well i don't know
but maybe it might be possible so what's
the recommendation here what's what am i
going towards i'm going to recommend
that you encapsulate behavior like this
there's no
reasonable
need for exposing all of these details
to a developer if you're using this as
access tokens for apis why don't we
verify this with a security library why
don't we provide our developers as
security champions as a security team or
as
concerned co-developers why don't we
provide
them or ourselves with a library that
says here's how you handle that token
you throw it in there and it will verify
all of these things for you without you
having to worry about it any of the
details and it will give you the claims
or an exception
or whatever works in your language
silent error is always good
but that way that's a takeaway here that
way we encapsulate this security
behavior
in libraries we absolve the developers
of that responsibility of having to know
all of these details having to make sure
that all of these details are correct
and having to do it over and over again
and that's a very very important pattern
that's the only way we're ever going to
solve this thing otherwise there's
always going to be someone who
misunderstands which parts function to
use
which is very easy to happen as you have
seen and which can cause massive
vulnerabilities in our applications
so the next step is
we have a library how do we get
developers to use that library well
that's a very good question so how do
you scale this up how do you allow
people across an organization to use
that and the best reference i have for
that is this story from netflix it's an
article from netflix on how they
integrate security into their process
and it's actually a really interesting
read it's a pretty long article but i
recommend you take the 11 minutes that
medium says it takes you to read that to
actually read that article and the gist
of it is it goes like this netflix they
when they did security the security team
had like this massive checklist for
security
like hundreds and hundreds of things a
team was supposed to do to build a
secure application on netflix and they
went to the teams and development teams
and said like hey here's your security
checklist can you go through this please
can you make sure that your application
is secure
and they said like oh yeah sure
let me find some time we'll do that
and three months later the security team
went back like
dear developers where's that security
checklist if you don't like yeah we'll
get to that we'll get to that
give us some time well we don't have
time right now and it didn't work very
well it was like a very painful process
and resulted in a lot of issues in real
world applications so they they took a
hard look at their approach and said
like why are we bothering developers
with having to do security
it doesn't really make any sense and
they call this the paved road as in
they want to make it as easy as possible
for development teams to do things
securely and the way to do that the way
to get it done is by helping them do
their regular jobs
plus security and what they did is they
built a tool that bootstraps a new
project within within the netflix
ecosystem with a few commands so instead
of spending half a day of setting up
repos and dns and this and that and that
they just said like okay
here's the command you run this and we
will do that all for you we'll create a
dns record so we will set up the
properties we will provide you a code
skeleton that integrates with single
sign-on and all of this stuff
and it does all a whole bunch of
security things under the hood sets
everything up
and developers basically went from half
a day setup to 10 minutes
and they didn't even have to go to the
security checklist because that was
integrated from the beginning in that
whole process and that made everybody's
lives easier and all of a sudden
security adoption was very
straightforward and very easy to follow
up on and that's a good way to make this
happen in your company as well help
developers do their job in a better and
more straightforward way by including
security as well
if you tell them like hey man all that
job stuff you can forget about that
just use this library they're probably
going to be like oh thank you awesome
damn done
that's how it works and you can reuse
that library across applications as well
like if you have 15 applications that
all handle that same type of access
token coming from that same
authorization server guess what the same
library can handle that for all 15
applications that's a huge gain that you
have there
and there's a secondary benefit here as
well
because you encapsulate this behavior
your system becomes more flexible you're
able to change your system when you want
to change it want to change the
signature scheme on a jot or the
algorithm sure
update the part where you issue it and
the part where you verify it in that
shared library
and you're done
you want to change the token format you
can do that because you have
encapsulated that extracted them away
extracted it out of the application and
put that in an encapsulated library
making your system more flexible
and this reminded me creating this slide
reminded me of my software engineering
classes at university where you you
learn these patterns it's like yeah
encapsulation and abstraction are
important and as a student you're like
okay if you say so
and then afterwards you see this in
practice and you're like oh yeah this
actually makes a lot of sense now i can
change this whenever i need and nobody
else has to worry about that and it
doesn't break any part of the
application
so yeah a whole bunch of lessons we can
learn about appsec
enough about json web tokens that's
that's where we're going to wrap it up
let's talk about reacts
react
frontline applications completely
different topic no api security no
authorization tokens no we're building
front ends now in a browser which is
always again good fun especially because
of problems like cross-site scripting so
what's cross-site scripting
here's an example of a very simple react
application
purely for demonstration purposes and we
have a bit of an html template where we
add some data from provided by a user
this is a restaurant review application
or at least a small part of it where we
have a review with a title and the
contents of that review
and if one of your users provides us a
review the user can be a tad malicious
and they can provide us a review that
contains evil code
and in the example you see here we have
some html embedded in the review and the
red part is a dangerous part it's an
image source none which means the image
the browser will see that image tag try
to load it doesn't find image none png
gives an error and instead it executes
that on error event handler which is an
alert which is
very non-dangerous but if that code
executes if the alert should pop up
by accident or by mistake that's a
vulnerability then the attacker can do
anything else as well the moment the
attacker can execute javascript code
your application is compromised because
that means that i as a malicious user
can upload that review into the system
and every one of you looking for
restaurants in oslo tonight
will get that review and that code
executes in your browser so i provide
the code
submit it and it executes in all your
browsers
when you visit the application and that
gives me control over your application i
can now start creating reviews in your
name uh change the looks of the
application steal your passwords and so
on and so on pretty dangerous and
basically means game over for the
front-end application
so what happens if we put this
into that template using react well
it looks like this
awesome
there's no code execution that's good
that's because react is protecting you
by default so react is not stupid here
react knows exactly what you're doing
when you write code as you see at the
top react is like oh you're going to put
data in an html page that you know
that's dangerous right that results in
cross-site scripting so i'm going to
escape these characters i'm going to
translate the open tag for an html
element into the ampersand lt semicolon
which is the representation of that
character so the browser doesn't see
that as code and react does that by
default for all these data bindings
awesome
and if the react developers are like yes
i chose the right framework the other
ones do that as well angular does it and
amber does it and vue does it and all
the decent frameworks do that by default
that's
standard behavior they understand these
templates and they know how to secure
that by default awesome
good
finally secure by default we're getting
there
and then
you end up in the use case where you
want to render pretty content
you want the user to allow something
like ck editor data so they enter some
rich text format in an editor and behind
the scenes it's going to submit html to
your server or your api and you want to
render that html in the browser
well if you want to render this with
react and you use the curly braces it's
going to encode all of these characters
it's going to look like crap it's really
your users users users are not going to
be very happy
and neither will you and your boss won't
be very happy and so on and so on so how
do you render this as html well
rendering untrusted data as html that's
dangerous
that's dom-based process scripting
which hasn't been introduced like a long
time ago as jim covered in his keynote
this morning so how do you do that in
react how do you output this and react
well
there's a property you can use for that
called dangerously set in html
how do you use that one well
you can kind of guess you called
dangerously set in html you provided an
object and in that object you provide
underscore underscore html as a property
with the review data and if you have the
data at the bottom and the code on top
and you insert this you see this
rendered html you can see that i'm a
very skilled designer as well by the way
and
you get the alert
you have a massive vulnerability in your
application yeah of course i mean it
says dangerously set in html what did
you expect that was going to be safe
no of course not this is dangerous for a
reason and reacts as like okay in html
is dangerous so you know what we're
going to make you very aware of that by
marking this as dangerous
so don't use it the wrong way because
that's dangerous
you're supposed to sanitize that review
what you're supposed to do is you're
supposed to call a sanitizer dump urify
is your sanitizer of choice that's a
solid library working in javascript
applications so you call down purify you
tell it like i have a piece of dirty
html that review i want you to make it
safe to include in the page
and down purify is going to parse that
html it's going to walk the tree and
keeps everything that it knows to save
it as a list of safe elements and
attributes and everything that it
doesn't know like an on error it's like
blah on error out
and what you end up with is safe html
that you can include in the page and
that's what you're supposed to do when
you want to output stuff into the page
you put this into the page you get that
the bold tag is there the image tag is
there the link is there except the on
error part that is gone so the code
execution vulnerability has disappeared
this is the correct way of outputting
html in react applications
all right
so what's the takeaway here what do we
gain by doing that
well by doing this we basically prevent
accidental misuse of a very very
dangerous feature that's what this is
all about
why
well for two reasons
the less common reason is autocomplete
and ides if you just autocomplete stuff
and you drop it in there then you may
have no idea what you're doing so if you
also complete something that's called
dangerously set an instrument in your
html that should trigger a bell that's
reason number one more common is because
if you copy basis from stack overflow
and it doesn't say dangerous and you
have no idea what you're doing which is
primary reason that to make this
property called dangerously set in html
so if you paste this and you look at it
and you're like
i should probably look into that
that's essentially what we're doing here
all right
awesome
so does does that wrap up react security
well unfortunately not so
i've been teaching this for a while now
i've been teaching this for a couple of
years and
the more i teach this the less convinced
i become that this is actually a good
way of doing things and that's that's
why i want to talk about this in a bit
more depth because what we're doing here
is we're basically warning developers
like hey watch out this is dangerous
like watch out there's a cliff here if
you fall down you probably die
and they were like yeah go ahead anyway
we warned you so if you fall it's your
own problem and that's that's about it
we don't really care about what happens
after that and what turns what happens
in practice is that this works as
intended i mean if you slip on that
trail you will die
and if you
make a mistake in your recta react
application you
create an intentional cross-site
scripting vulnerability
so that process
kind of strikes me as wrong
and if you put yourself in the
perspective of a developer you
find that dangerously set international
property somewhere and you're you're
trying to do a good job
i honestly believe that most developers
want to build secure applications so
what do you do
you look up what that means right
why is this called dangerous what should
i do instead and you're going to find
your react documentation the official
docs and the official docs are going to
say like dangerously set in html yeah
you have to watch out because this can
cause cross cross scripting attacks
and then the second sentence is so to
set it anyway you have to pass this
object like this so we can remind you
that it's dangerous
it literally says in the last line to
remind yourself that this is dangerous
and this screenshot is the entire
documentation on this property
that's it
so we're basically expecting developers
to
understand what this means
i can promise you if you've never heard
of crosstalk scripting this thing means
nothing to you it's like
okay then
you have to look up how to fix it
correctly
as a developer you have to trust that
the developer finds the right source
because there's no solution here there's
just a wrong example
then you have to trust that they use
that approach in the right way
and that they apply it correctly in
their application on every single use of
dangerously set in their html
that's kind of the thoughts and prayers
equivalent of application security right
it's like
hoping that things work out
and in practice it doesn't
here's an example from signal messenger
one of the most secure messaging apps in
in the landscape of messengers and their
desktop application was built in react
react in electron and
you can see again it's a very nice pull
request to give pull requests are
awesome for screenshots and on the left
you can see the bad code example
dangerously set in html like whoopsie
and on the right they have
transformed that in a secure way of
rendering that
and the case in point here is that it's
good to mark something dangerous
but it's not enough it doesn't stop
abuse of that feature stop accidental
misuse of that feature it just helps a
little bit
to inform people that have no idea what
it does that this might be somewhat
dangerous
it doesn't magically enable developers
to use that feature securely
and at last
second to last word is
kind of important here feature
the use of dangerously set inner html is
a feature
which means if you want to output html
in react applications there is no well
i'm not going to tell you the other ways
because they're even worse but there's
no by design way
to output html except for using
dangerously set in your html
so if you're building an application and
you want to render html even if you want
to get it right even if you want to make
it secure you still have to use
dangerously set in html
what does that mean in practice in
practice it means your code base is
going to be littered with calls to a
dangerous api
there's going to be dozens of places
with dangerously set enriched amount in
your code base
and that's a very very
bad idea
because it stops you from doing
a bunch of other things for security
let's say that you're a responsible
developer like okay we're going to build
more secure react apps so we're going to
start scanning our react apps for bad
code
you can use a tool like semgrep or a
linting tool there's linting rules for
this as well and samgrap is going to run
a react rule base
just like this
and if it does it's going to come back
and says like
i found a potential issue now semigraph
is not the smartest tool it's very fast
and efficient but not very smart so it
just looks for dangerous api calls
dangerous patterns but it doesn't know
if this is actually dangerous or not
it's not a full-on static analysis tool
it's just a pattern matching tool
basically hence sam grep
it finds on line 62 dangerously set in
html so it's like
i know that that is dangerous because i
copy pasted the warning from the react
documentation uh to be honest here um
but it says like yeah you have to watch
out because if you misuse this feature
you have across that scripting
vulnerability and now as a developer you
can look at this and be like
uh-huh
but i'm using dom purify like philippe
said so this is safe right
yes it is this is safe
good the bottom line kind of shows that
this is a demo app three files in a
react app that means nothing and one
finding is also nothing in reality it's
going to be 45 files and 10 findings or
4 500 files and god knows how many
findings
more like it yes thank you
what do you do then like oh there's a
hundred findings okay good i'm gonna
scroll through every one of them to see
if all of them are safe you can do that
once
are you gonna do that again next week
probably not
so this basically means by littering
your code base which is dangerously set
in html you lose the ability to scan for
misuses of that api because these tools
are not built for that purpose
linting rules wouldn't be better by the
way and static analysis tools don't
support react very well
and that leaves us with
unhygienic code it leaves us with code
full of dangerous patterns that might
may or may not be safe depending on how
you use them and that's not very good
this pattern is a really bad
anti-pattern
what can we do better well what if we
would provide proper semantics what if
we would be able to explain
in code that this is actually safe by
using something like this
save html what do you want to create oh
a paragraph and this should be the
content of that element
if you look at the code at the bottom
this is clear to you what that does even
if you have never heard of any react
code you mean like save html like oh
yeah this is probably good
this is a clean way of doing that and
that component is not very complicated i
mean the code on top is how you use it
and then at the bottom there's the react
component actually does that
and what does it do
it creates an element and sets the inner
html using dangerously set inner html
and don't purify the proper way of doing
that
and your code is a lot cleaner
on top
and it looks a lot better semantically
correct
and that brings us back to this one we
covered this before
encapsulate security behavior in
libraries to make developers life easier
instead of teaching developers like use
dump urify everywhere
hopefully the right way we can now teach
them like hey
just use that safe html component that
we're using in our organization and
you're covered we'll take care of that
for you want to output html save html
want to output html with some specific
styling save html with styling done
easy straightforward
and you get something in addition to
that
because of encapsulating that
behavior we now get the ability again to
scan our application because if we run
semgrep instead of 10 findings we have
one finding
look at where it is in the save html.js
component on line 6 because that's the
only place where we ever use dangerously
set in your html
and you can get rid of that warning by
going to that component and marking that
one as
please ignore this
that's the only way you can do that by
the way never do that for crappy code
only do it for code you have manually
verified that it's secure that you're
100 sure then you can tell semgrep let's
just keep this between us
you don't have to report about that
that's that's our little secret
and when you do that
you get zero findings
awesome
an empty list of stuff to do that's
everybody likes that right
it's been a long time since i got there
but
but it's not the empty list that matters
what matters is you can set up the
scanning tool
on your code base
and it's not going to find anything
until you hire an intern next month and
the intern writes their first react
feature and they find some crap code
example somewhere on the internet
dangerously set in html blah blah bam
you run your semgrap tool in your build
pipeline in your commits
in your commit hook in github and some
girls will be like hold on no no one
findings
or five depends on what they're writing
we don't do that this is a dangerous api
call and you can customize the message
even and say like hey in this
organization we use a safe html
component which will handle this for you
and that's the way we do things
you gain the ability again to scan your
code base for potentially dangerous
patterns allowing you to catch them the
moment they're introduced and stop them
from ever existing in your production
application
that's a really
really important takeaway
we're basically using code hygiene
for security success which is like the
most catchy takeaway ever right
but this this really helps because we
encapsulate dangerous behavior we hide
it away we avoid
littering our code base with potentially
insecure patterns so that we can
actually catch
the true insecure patterns when they are
introduced so they can't hide in the
noise anymore
and applying this
to other security concepts i could keep
going but i'm not going to do that apply
this to other security concepts that's
essentially the only way we're ever
going to scale security across large
applications and organizations because
no tool will ever be able to deal with
all of these things automatically
but by helping
tools by encapsulating this behavior we
can easily help tools gain more control
help tools and essentially win at scale
for application security
so is application security too hard
well yeah i kind of think it is
we can't expect developers to figure all
of this out because it's not just this
one thing it's all of these other things
and developers don't have the time to
learn or to follow like three days of
security courses to figure out how to
put value safely in react well
some of them do because i have them in
my classes luckily
that's not that's never going to work
very well
and if you follow the workshop at the
conference here you know that at the end
of the workshop you have like a whole
ton of things to look at like oh yeah
just keep this in mind keep that in mind
and that's never going to work because
it's only going to grow and grow and
grow so we have to do something else
we've been doing this for 25 30 years
and it doesn't work
it no longer scales at all there's too
many guidelines too many details too
many nuances
that we have to take away from
developers
the question part
the answer to that question is
it doesn't have to be yes appstack is
hard
fortunately jim gave a keynote this
morning to tell us how abstract has
gotten a lot better that's good
and i think we can push that even
further i think we can push it further
by learning from these good intentions
all of the things i talked about here
were not malicious acts the react
developers was not a conspiracy among
the people building react like yeah
we're going to screw them over by
calling this dangerous and having them
use it everywhere it's no they tried
their best
to mark this as dangerous
and it kind of doesn't work in practice
that's the takeaway here good intentions
absol not so much but the road at least
to where we're going is based with good
intentions so what we have to aim for is
the right level of abstraction
you have to look for that abstraction
that helps developers get their job done
support them in their job and focus on
proper and usable security preferably
with the right semantics
and i believe we can do if we can do
that we can make things significantly
better towards the future that's my
message here for the conference and with
that i want to thank you for being here
[Applause]
if you have any questions
i'll be happy to answer them right now
you have someone with a mic so let's
make them run around a bit if there are
questions
healthy workouts
yeah no rush with the picture apparently
the last slide stays on until the next
speaker arrives so
you'll have plenty of time to do that
all right anything
all abstract topics are fair game so
yes there's questions over here
yeah sure that's that's good i'll repeat
the question uh for the live streaming
with the audience dot first did the
third option actually validate the
signature quickly yes
so the question was um with the job
example of parse and parse claims jws
does the parse claims jws actually work
more securely yes i actually verified
that so i went beyond the autocompletion
suggestions and i tried them out and the
parse indeed does accept an algonan
token parse claims jws
requires a jlus is the abbreviation for
json webb's signature so it requires a
signature it doesn't move forward
without signature
would have been better if it was a
function like
bars without verifying signature and
bars securely that would have been a bit
more meaningful in this case but yeah
fair question
anybody else yeah
just shout out
okay so the question is if you call
something safe html how should
developers be aware of security issues
well that's the whole thing they
shouldn't
if you use
in that file
okay yeah yeah so the question is how
can you ensure that the library you're
using or the component you're using is
actually safe instead of containing
vulnerabilities well that's that's a
fair question um that's where security
people come in so
in an organization of reasonable size
you typically have developers and you
have security champions embedded in
development teams and you have a
security team which is which are
dedicated appstick experts and they will
be able to tell you that this is the
right way to help you develop that
component that library and they tell you
this is the right way of doing things or
you just can just copy paste the code
from my slides and use that
no need for it
having a security but yeah you'll have
to rely on somebody to provide you with
the correct way to build that secure
component and from that point on you can
use that so as a developer and don't
necessarily recommend that every
developer now starts building their own
security components um but their
recommendation is more likely that the
security team
provides that or or a few people with
more security expertise do provide that
or you hire a consultant to provide it
for you and
the moment you have that you can start
using it
well in that case we can just burn the
whole castle down right
there's always yes there's always going
to be mistakes that's
the inherent nature find good people
that's that's my advice um and
yeah of course validate and test and
guarantee but
trust me even don't purify that
sanitizer has mistakes but
when there's a mistake they are quick to
catch it they quick to fix it and
everybody can update that you'll have to
account for mistakes will always be
there
building perfect software is impossible
so i would suggest you find a different
profession but finding something where
no mistakes ever happen
is also not going to go well
i'm a chef for example as well i went to
evening school for to cooking school and
in the kitchen that's a very good
example there's always mistakes like
all the time something goes wrong you
just have to account for that and
and pivot on the fly and deal with that
and and the same with software security
there's always going to be mistakes
there's always going to be that um bad
morning where you screw it up just like
with everything and
you'll have to deal with it anyway so
set up processes to deal with that that
would be my advice
and if you
don't trust your own code then ask
someone to review it
that would be the best way to ensure
it's safe
who you yep react to
instead of having a company internal
html to us
okay
hold on hold on
why are you mentioning angular
angular that this is a very interesting
question so the react people
react has this
idea of being a component library
they're not claiming to be a framework
they're a component library like hey we
allow you to build components and you
can use them to build applications and
sanitization to react is out of scope
for what they're doing
they're they don't feel the need to
offer sanitization angular is a
framework much more heavyweight so all
the react developers hate it because
angular has like it's my way or the
highway basically but if angular's way
is something you can find yourself in
angular is a very good framework which
i'm a fan of and angular does
sanitization by default angular set like
yes screw this we're not going to allow
developers to do this themselves because
we've seen this in the old version
angular 1.x they're going to screw it up
we have plenty of stack overflow
examples that actually make something
safe by just saying like yeah whatever
and that's a very bad thing so in
angular 2 plus they said like screw it
nobody can touch this again we're going
to do this by default if you assign
something as html into the page we will
sanitize it for you
you can't even turn it off you can't
touch that mechanism
and that's a much better approach in my
opinion
because
you get this out of the box you don't
have to write your own safe html
component you just use the things the
angular array and you're good but even
that is not enough and that's very
interesting because i do angular
security workshops and i explain this
whole crosstalk scripting thing i talked
for an hour about crosstalk scripting
and then the conclusion is like yeah
angular does all of this out of the box
people are like why the hell you're
talking about it then it's like yeah
because here's the way you can bypass
that there's a function called bypass
security trust html which
takes some html and says like yeah this
is safe don't touch it
and what what happens when i explain
that is people use the github search
feature like search in my organization
for bypass security trust html and they
come back to me like an hour later like
yeah crap we had a vulnerability that
uses exactly that function
because they had a scenario that has to
do a little bit
that had to enable behavior that the
senatorizer doesn't allow but they need
it for their customers and the only way
to sidestep the sanitizer is by fully
disabling it for that piece of data
which they did and functionally it works
but it allows any arbitrary piece of
code as well
so why don't we do it more by default
well because react doesn't think it's
necessary and even if you do it there's
still ways to mess it up so in angular
the example i give there instead of
using this bypass security i tell people
why don't you build
it's called a pipe in angular where you
can pass things through like sanitize
with style
and that tells you exactly what it does
without having to use bypass security
trust html over all over your code same
principle just
a little less common in angular than in
react
the other frameworks are more like
reacto so amber and vue i know about
those though they don't do sanitization
by default either so you'll you're
responsible for that yourself as well
all right anything else
going once
going twice
all right
thank you very much for being here enjoy
the rest of the conference if you want
to learn about api security by the way
i'm back here tomorrow morning with
another talk so um
come see what that's about and enjoy the
conference and a party tonight
[Applause]
you